you know that when I was on break it
gave me some insight of what's really
important it gave me some ideas around
what I really want to focus on in the
future and it made me ask what is Jake
Paul doing what is Jake Paul doing right
now huh what is he up to that little
snake Oh jakey Jake has he finally gone
fully bald yet these are the questions
I've been thinking about what do we got
you tuber Jake Paul launches
entrepreneur how to platform financial
freedom movement
yes Jake Paul is a person I look at when
I own I envision financial freedom okay
let's see let's dig into this this is
interesting to me they say were entitled
and lazy who is they Jake huh they tell
us to go to college get a job retire at
65 how's that working out for us how's
that working out for us so smug
you're not 65 Jake you can become
financially free by paying me money all
right trust me you're understand it
starts by paying me money ignore all
these endless content on YouTube with
actual legitimate people talking about
financial advice that actually has some
legitimacy and and trustworthy and and
weight to them but no really really what
we need to do is we need to pay Jake
Paul your parents happy are they living
the life they wanted I don't bring no I
think they are I think they are I don't
think what she's selling my parents on
this is over one trillion dollars in
student loan debt and people with
outdated education who can't even get a
job for the student loans they took out
student loan is the cheapest loan you
can ever get it's one of the most fair
loans it's a great loan to actually take
advantage of it's such dog to be like oh
my by student loans if you use it
correctly of course maybe we're too
young to have experiences yet but if
you're not then you know exactly what
I'm talking about
I don't had enough of it our generation
is better than this we deserve better
we're smarter so what's
solution okay what is he generation one
that inspires people to take action to
achieve vision this is not a product
this is a movement
oh it's literally in the name I didn't
even realize now the dreams our parents
have for us or our society we need a
movement that inspires people to live
life on their toes not someone else a
movement that anyone who's a breach
guards expensive becoming financially
free from the societal cookie cutter
nine-to-five jobs we are all told to
have our future is in our hands are you
with me I'm okay thank you though what
the hell was that
did you guys catch they are you with me
are you with me are you with me no
definitely not now why did he do that
this channel has 72 subscribers well
this is really taken up there's there's
one more video before we dig into this
meet some of the experts ok learn from
me and a dozen other experts and
millionaires learn from me and a dozen
other experts
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 maybe if you've stayed
in school Jake you wouldn't know what a
dozen is Jesus Christ break free from
the normal 9 to 5 and live life on your
terms my achieving financial freedom
from the homie Mark lack the king of
personal branding who's helped the
students generate over three hundred
million dollars online following this
strategy let me guess it's just a bunch
of people that you don't know who it is
basically and Fleischman he's the
youngest of ten flights from is in I got
a pay twenty bucks right now
learn from my homie Trev and e-commerce
expert with ten years of experience
oh my god trap you know trap of course
eating he sold eight figures online and
created products for some of the biggest
brands in the world like Star Wars
minions and WWE join the movement
join the movement I like how they're
supposed to be experts on marketing and
all these things they don't even link
what the website is in any of the videos
will teach you all the tricks we treat
you all don't link the website kind of
marketing is this I'll just Google
financial freedom movement
that'll do it right okay so it took a
while but I found the website your terms
dream goals financial freedom oh wow
look at that well Disney's in on this do
you really think they are what what are
they done for this they always add these
like what do they mean they don't mean
anything cutting-edge mentorship
coaching and training who are these
people what is wrong with that guy's
face you get personal his personal
rituals he has rituals and secret
formula mm-hmm live weekly video
coaching calls Wow can't wait to join in
those okay so there's more to be named
soon that's why there's more people
coming in on this all right let's look
at these if you're a photographer and
you go shoot for Jay Paul for free a
bunch of shots right well a lot of other
influencers and brands follow Jake like
a jigsaw noses blessing this shot but
the same concept applies you film for
them or photograph for them and then
Jake might follow them and he wants to
hire you I might follow it and wants to
hire you a brand might follow that guys
what you really need to do in this
tutorial of financial freedom is you
need to work for Jake Paul for free is
this him rationalizing for himself that
he did this whole thing for free what oh
my god it's sale it's not 40 pounds per
month oh wow that's so generous do not
write 44 times of Netflix now it's just
half don't worry guys click here to
enroll now absolutely I'm sold
who is this for his followers who wants
to become financially free he's he's 8
year olds his fellow 8 year olds who's
just struggling grinding out there they
just want to reach that financial
freedom man come on the freedom fam
we're a family
top price is I'll fly you out to film a
vlog with me and I'll share to my
millions of followers I wonder if you'll
actually follow up on any of this
because the thing is Jake's already done
a similar scheme of what was it called
it was called influence it was the exact
same thing where he said you want to
become big social media star like me I'm
big social media star you need to pay me
alright last thing they posted was in
November 2018 50% sale 50% sale
and the best part about this is the site
is down like you can't even reach it
anymore man
if you go to join now on financial
freedom it seems like a bad idea to pay
the hundred and fifty upfront you know
just in case he decides to remove the
whole website in which he definitely
will where's my login all right here we
go
all right so this is the this is the
page this is how it looks like you can
add your favorites this is a good thing
you can have your notes that's pretty
cool I can add a note here how do it how
do you add a note no notes found so
let's start the training I'm ready to
learn financial freedom here we go
I don't really care about Jake Paul I'm
only here for Dane Fleshman all right I
only want to know what Dane Fleshman has
to say that's really why I paid for no
one's liking their Fleshman stuff don't
worry I got you Dan I got you can I
dislike the other ones I'm only here for
Dane do you think these kids are signing
up to get a nine hour course of Billie
Jean I don't want to belittle maybe he
probably knows more than I do but I just
don't see the value for Jake Paul's
audience so I'm not gonna show that
footage because I'm pretty sure it'll
get copyrighted but it's basically the
person in your viewing Jake someone
that's more qualified has more
experience and actually seems to know
someone at least they're just interview
and Jake and talking about Jake stuff so
if you want to pay 20 bucks a month for
that I mean I'm not gonna stop you
my favorite part of this signing up to
this course is not just for Dan
Fleischman it's for the community that's
right you get access to the private Jake
Paul financial freedom community so here
are the hurry I don't have any friends
I like this bend over what's up Jake
Pollard's if you're tired of all the
hate for Jake Paul like this post smash
like I'll be the first one it's really
people just posting memes or asking if
how can I unsubscribe how can I stop
paying this I don't want to pay for this
and this guy replying you guys are so
stupid why do you want to join a
movement and then cancel your
subscription we check in do by the way
well maybe you don't want to pay 40
bucks a month
they start charging you 20 what started
to say that they're gonna charge you 40
after your sign up right if it was is it
always 50% of my photos I'll create an
album when they launch this thing they
had this whole event it's gonna be
massive right everyone's gonna want to
come to this financial freedom thing I
mean it looks from the looks of
engagement and all that it looks like
luckily not many people are buying into
this and then you can look at the launch
which is great so here it is it's gonna
be all over it it's gonna be a whole
line it's gonna be tan akan 3.0 and
here's the reality a bunch of kids about
what a dozen maybe I don't know how much
that is and I think this is for the
people that bought the merch or
something like that there's more cops
there than actual people visiting
what does it say ideas ideas are without
execution I thought it was gonna say
education
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that looked like I had a lot of fun who
wouldn't want to pay to go there it's
the same I don't know what's going on
great what a great event well I thought
this was a fight financial freedom Jake
it's very passionate Jake Paul is
complaining about how in school he
didn't know why he was there we have
some amazing experts
and actually learn and actually land
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right no other reason
Lennie's pizza get ready to quit school
and just pay 20 bucks a month because
that's all you really need there's some
amazing quotes from this interview that
Jake did with variety as well where he
was saying I was like why are we sitting
in class right now learning the
quadratic formula when we should be
learning about taxes and insurance
teacher please I need to learn about
taxes and insurance right now
he said like that where's my taxes huh
you know for this quadratic formula
I need financial freedom I am I supposed
to get it Jake Paulus it reason why no
one no one likes youtubers it's just
like well I'm probably a guilty as well
never mind and then he says that he
dropped out of school at 11th grade
completing the diploma through an online
course I just got the answer from a
cheat site and put it in and didn't have
to do any work why you're so epically
smart Jake I bet you were probably the
smartest kid in the class weren't you
I'll wait you say you are oh this is
sweet talking about this our education
system it's worthless worthless
I'm fed up I don't know how to cap on
life maybe you and your school you'll
learn how to write Jesus Christ is mess
if you're confused at what the event is
tomorrow
basically I'm sick of our education
system and how is teaching kids zero
real life skills for them to secure
their own their their own future this is
embarrassing
I'm creating a movement for everyone who
wants to take life into their own hands
and learn real life skills from actual
professionals why are kids sitting in
film class film learning from a teacher
has never even made a film these
dumbasses and that's just one example he
hasn't made any more don't worry guys
that's just one example there's no
there's no need to refute it cuz he's
got a whole backlog of ideas and
arguments here it is I was the kid in
class I like how we capitalized so
listen it who was the smartest doubt
okay couldn't apply myself because I
thought it was so stupid to be sitting
there I thought they was so stupid to be
sitting there it's all we are thought
where are my taxes where's my insurance
classes it's so disingenuous to put
forth like this is what you're
passionate about when in reality the
only thing Jay Paul has shown himself to
be passionate about is making money
Jake Paul is the kind of celebrity that
doesn't have any real value so all they
do is they project this image of wealth
and now he's monetizing that to get more
money he's like he's stuck in this loop
where he has to pretend that he it's all
about money to make more money but in
reality you could replace Jake poll with
anything or anyone it wouldn't make a
difference he's literally empty and no
one the message is fine like I agree
that so much of the school system is
outdated but what the [ __ ] is jake paul
gonna teach you about this or so bozo
some composer you never heard about like
i said before there's a ton of actual
inspiring legitimate people that you can
listen to on youtube if you want to for
free not monthly payment i know this is
just another ed flood scam i don't need
to tell you or because you already know
it this is a complete [ __ ] there's
no point in saying it but i do think
it's interesting and these things are
still happening it's like Jesus Christ
dude alright guys sorry but I gotta keep
watching another how to develop a launch
mo mo I just got to keep going stuff
I'll see you guys tomorrow if you
enjoyed this video smash like and make
sure to subscribe 68% this and subscribe
can we get it 267 please guys see you
tomorrow Hagel hey hey